matthew stafford and the lions taking on
the vikings in minneapolis some
interesting subplots here adrian
peterson
back in minnesota everson griffin back
in minnesota
a strange little back and forth that
feels just a bit contrived everson
griffin mad at
mike zimmer the head coach because he
said griffin's a good player not a great
player
i look do whatever you have to do to
motivate yourself ever since i got no
problem with that
but kenny goliday out with a hip injury
for the lions
stafford on the covet 19 reserve list
because he and his family were exposed
to someone
who was positive for the virus he's got
to test negatively on saturday and
sunday to play he's banned from the team
until sunday so he's walking through the
door
the vikings are down some corners even
if they had everybody healthy
their corners aren't very good there's
an opportunity there for matthew
stafford
so i look it's an elimination game as
far as i'm concerned and the winner may
be done too
but i think whoever loses that game
between the lions and the vikings
for all practical purposes shireen has
done for 2020
yeah big game for for both teams and i
know matthew stafford wants to play and
it all
is now in the hands of the covet test
and it was close contact his wife
confirmed that and it was not a positive
test
chase daniel said he's acting like he's
the starter but the lions hope that
matthew stafford is back and matthew
stafford hope that he's back and
you know he's just kind of been so so
this year he really needs to step up in
a big game and play well and i know it's
going to be hard without having a week
of practice
everything was virtual for him but but
he needs to step up and have a big game
for the lions or there will be doubts i
think going forward about his future
in detroit did they start looking for
another quarterback at some point he's
been there an awfully long time and
for whatever reason whether it's a
change in coaches offensive coordinators
everything else they just haven't taken
that step
mike that that i expected him to take
anyway i had them going to the playoffs
as a wildcard team and
i don't think they're going to get there
again like you said this week's an
elimination game
but i don't think they're going to get
there the way they're playing at three
and four right now
yeah i think the lions have slid to a
status where i'm not picking them to
make the playoffs until the first year
i'm wrong about it
and they make it because for whatever
reason it's just not clicking and maybe
they do just enough this year
that ownership decides to bring back gm
bob quinn and bring back coach matt
patricia
but it may be without matthew stafford
next year this guy's been you know i i
don't know
friend he's performed and produced like
a franchise quarterback
but if you never win a playoff game i
mean at least kirk cousins has won a
playoff game
matthew you know and and kirk cousins
is as middle of the pack ish frankly as
it gets
in the nfl right now you got it you got
to have team success at some point to be
a franchise quarterback you can't just
be
a stat machine on a bad team because at
some point
you're responsible for the team not
being good and i i still have
burning in my brain a story that came
out
from the lion several years ago reggie
bush was playing for the lions at the
time and the lions were struggling they
had expectations
they had a good team calvin johnson was
on the team and they were struggling and
dominic and sue was still on the lines
at the time
and reggie bush suggested a team meeting
you know players-only meeting you know
that the old desperation play to try to
get everybody pointed in the right
direction
and reggie bush was in the locker room
with a super bowl ring so i think he's
got a little cachet when it comes to
knowing what a team needs to get pointed
in the right direction
and stafford's attitude was now we don't
need it so he's always been kind of that
reluctant leader
and i just think that you can't just be
a passer you've got to be a
quarterback you've got to be a leader of
the team and he's never been that
it's just not wired into him and i think
that's one of the reasons why we haven't
seen the lions do more during the
11 years he's been there shireen yeah no
question mike
and and he hasn't taken that next step
he's put up a lot of statistics if you
know in fantasy he's been
fantastic but he hasn't been that good
for the lions when it comes to the win
losses getting the team the playoffs
winning playoff games
getting them a step toward a super bowl
they just haven't
taken that step and i know the changes
in coaches and offensive coordinators
and everything else affects quarterbacks
it just
does but he doesn't seem to be that
leader to take his guys to that next
level like we see so many quarterbacks
do the great ones do that it doesn't
matter
what receivers you give tom brady i know
he's got a lot of them this year but
when you look back over the years in new
england he didn't always have the
greatest of receivers
and he still managed to win in new
england and other quarterbacks like that
i mean aaron rodgers i mean he's got
devante adams who else does he have he
doesn't have those great receivers
they're not going to be all pro they're
not going to be pro bowl but
he manages to take those guys to a
different level and that's what we
haven't seen
from matthew stafford yet here's an
interesting question
if he's not playing for the lions
because the guy's still got
five six seven good years left he's
early thirties it feels like he's been
around forever
but he's still in his prime physically
and he's getting to that point where the
combination of remaining physical skills
plus your brain
from everything you've experienced it
comes together to create this coach
quarterback on the field that
that can't be fooled by anything
theoretically
it'll be fascinating to see who pounces
because i think if you put him in the
right place
with a team that already has strong
veteran leadership
a team that doesn't need a quarterback
to come in and take over
man you you could have a special outcome
for matthew stafford next year
you almost look at what indianapolis did
this year with with philip rivers a
situation like that where they have a
really good defense where they have some
weapons on offense
where they have a really good offensive
line i agree with you i think he
could be really good someplace else it
hasn't worked in detroit though
hey all due respect to philip rivers if
i'm chris ballard
the gm of the colts i say see you later
philip
hello matthew stafford in an instant
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports